on a amoud et l'or au coeur donc de
cette manifestation des pompiers en
colère mohamoud dès lors il ya des
pompiers à vos côtés j'espère qu'il nous
protège parce que vous avez pris à
priori un nouveau projectile vous aviez
déjà pris un jet de pétard plus tanner
vous avez encore été touchées comment
allez vous oh oui exactement il ya eu
plusieurs tirs de gaz lacrymogènes et
j'ai toujours recevoir quelque chose
puisque j'étais à quelques quelques
centimètres et heureusement que les
pompiers m'ont aidé et m'ont secouru
m'ont apporté un liquide pour que j'y
vois on peut plus claire plus clair en
tout cas là ça va un peu mieux on est
justement entouré de deux pompiers qui
sont ici et qui manifestent depuis 14h
sans relâche l'érection ils sont en
colère et depuis depuis 14h ce cortège
défile pas dans les rues lieu de paris 2
place de la république jusqu'ici à
nation et vous l'avez vu sur les sur les
images il ya eu des frictions entre
entre les policiers et les pompiers
guèye cette barricade qui a été bousculé
par plusieurs
plusieurs pompiers beaucoup ici elle est
extrêmement symbolique cette barricade
et il ya eu des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
nombreux de la par les forces de l'ordre
également des canons à eau de sapeurs
pompiers qui qui sont fatigués qu'ils
sont en colère ce sont leurs mots il ya
aujourd'hui cette réunion à 14 heures
qui était censé être ouvrir une porte
notamment concernant cette fameuse prime
du feu qui va être réévalué à 28% en
tout cas je vais laisser la parole aux
pompiers bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous pour est ce que c'est
important pour vous aujourd'hui de
manifester vous faites depuis juin 2019
alors c'est pour c'est important de
manifester déjà parce que comme vous
l'avez dit on en aimerait avoir eu
valeur
revalorisation pardon de la prime de feu
donc à 28% en est actuellement à 19% les
connais qui sont en face eux ont la
prime de feu enfin la voir leurs primes
de métier à risque justement à 28%
d'argent pas pourquoi nous sapeurs
pompiers on est considéré nous on sait
qu'on a volé tap
on n'est pas un métier à risque donc
tout va être mis à la juste valeur au
même niveau que nos collègues en face et
avoir la même prime de fait donc à 28%
meilleur on n'est pas là que pour ça non
plus on est là également aussi pour les
retraites on essaye d'avoir aussi notre
avantage c'est de garder les cinq à des
bonifications tous les cinq ans gardé
une année en fait modifications pour
notre retraite parce qu'on a un métier
qui est difficile tous les jours on est
confronté à de plus en plus déjà aux
agressions d'accord les interventions au
fur des années elle augmente les
effectifs diminuent donc les camions
manque de reconnaissance voilà déjà vu
le manque de reconnaissance ça fait déjà
des mois et des mois qu'on leur grève
pour ça plus les années passent plus les
interventions augmente par contre dans
les camions les effectifs diminuent
on part avec un fourgon incendie à 6 bat
en ce moment on n'est plus sûr du 4 une
ambulance d'accord on est à 3
normalement dans une ambulance balader
fois on parlera d'eux donc là les avis
publics est en danger la population est
en danger et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
manifeste notre colère et on aimerait
aussi donc justement avoir avalé
revalorisation de la prime de feu pour
nos retraites et aussi pour de
l'effectif est justement vous parlez de
la pénibilité nous nous en tant que
qu'un division c'est que le métier est
extrêmement difficile mais vous au
quotidien
en manque d'effectif comment est ce que
vous faites pas c'est très simple on
fait comme on fait comme médiateur c'est
des carences quand je vous ai dit ohlala
bilan sur parra 3 on parlera de pardon
au retour de brett à 3 bah ça c'est de
la sécurité pour les sapeurs pompiers on
intervient ça a des répercussions aussi
sur les gens que vous allez voir comment
est-ce qu'on traite l'humain quand on
n'est pas assez nombreux
bah vous savez on intervient on a on a
fait ça je pense que là tous les
sapeurs-pompiers qui sont là à la basse
et une passion d'accord sauf que là au
fur et à mesure des années bah notre
avancement de carrière déjà il est
réduit et je pense que il ya un manque
de considération de l'état
vous voyez aujourd'hui la colère on est
en face on intervient avec nos collègues
qui sont en face comment on peut voir ça
aujourd'hui que on sait gaz et on soit
l'un contre l'autre alors qu'au final au
dans la même galère parce que je sais
très bien que enfin saucisses en
sous-effectif c'est tout l'ensemble du
service public qui va pas en france
justement là quand thierry ces frictions
avec les policiers alors que beaucoup de
bien c'est assez paradoxal qu est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti bac est
ce que vous les jeudis c'est un mal être
général comment on peut en arriver là
aujourd'hui en 2020 à voir les
sapeurs-pompiers en phase d'essai
devoir lutter parce que l'état justement
mais ne fait pas son boulot si on en est
là c'est pas par rapport à eux en face
ni à nous ça vient de là où l état à eux
de prendre des mesures c'est des années
des années que ça dure
et là vous voyez le ras-le-bol général
des sapeurs-pompiers vous le voyez là
sauf qu'en face c'est très bien que le
ras le bol chez eux c'est la même chose
et on est obligé d'en arriver là
aujourd'hui c'est pas normal
est ce que vous êtes optimiste
finalement de 2 pour le pour l'avenir
vous vous le voyez très bien vous saurez
si vous souhaitez c'est optimiste
aujourd'hui collecte me font rire bah
ouais est ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui
des pompiers avec le sourire honnêtement
si vous voyez aujourd'hui des gens qui
viennent vous se courir avec le sourire
moi aujourd'hui je n'ai pas vu donc
comment voulez vous que
on interviennent dans de bonnes
conditions que les gens soient pris en
charge dans de bonnes conditions
quand on voulait que le service public
en général tourner correctement c'est
impossible pour moi je suis pas
optimiste
après on sait jamais pardon qui se
vouent disait mon collègue l'a dit il ya
un manque de moyens que répartis sur
votre travail finalement bien sûr il l'a
dit mon collègue je vais me répéter il
l'a dit il ya un manque de moyens et
c'est tout c'est comme ça et oui comme
tout le monde le sait ça ne se répéter
ça est pas la première fois qu'on vient
ici sur paris voilà comme l'a dit mon
collègue c'est l'étape
venez d'où roubaix est d'accord et vous
pas riches sont collectées
voilà mais on est à atterrir dans les
quartiers sensibles d'accord on
intervient on en revient dans des
quartiers où j'ai travaillé avec la
police d'accord on a des points de
rendez vous on est obligé d'attendre
est ce que vous savez est-ce que vous
pensez que à ce stade là on doit arriver
là on doit se protéger par rapport à
tout ça tout et civilité que ce soit
décroche à des injures du caillassage
armes ont donné leur laissa pompiers en
ont ras le bol
d'accord aussi dé la noce c'est mignon
qu'on soit payé en conséquence que notre
valorisation que l'amitié soit considéré
comme un métier à risque que la prime
qu'on a nous la prime de feu soit au
même niveau que les métiers à risques
d'accord et qu'on internet en sécurité
pour nous d'accord et surtout pour la
population si on intervient avec une
ambulance à deux personnes ne pourra pas
faire le même travail qu'à 3 donc la vie
de la population est vraiment en danger
est là faut vraiment vraiment vraiment
sillonné la sirène d'alarmé l'état ça va
pas si on continue comme ça on va tout
vous voyez il ya beaucoup de collègues
qui se retourne à août il y en a marre
comment ça se fait que on s'engage étant
jeune on se dit c'est un métier les
camions rouges c'est une passion et que
10 ans après balleux collègues il en a
marre ils arrêtent les sapeurs-pompiers
franchement demandé aux anciens il ya 20
ans si il dit un jour ise bas j'ai
quitté les pompiers tout ça allait
jamais de c'est que là ça fait cinq six
ans mais plusieurs années il y en a
marre franchement il a vraiment vraiment
marquants merci beaucoup en tout cas
pour toutes
merci à vous vous l'avez entendu grégory
des sapeurs-pompiers qui sont
sont en colère et qui en tout cas ne
lâcheront pas le combat et continuerons
à manifester ici c'est en tout cas ce
que la plupart des sapeurs pompiers nous
ont expliqué ici malgré les frictions
qu'il peut y avoir
ils vont continuer à manifester on va
essayer un petit peu d'avancé et de vous
montrer ce qui se passe ici derrière
nous une ici en tout cas ça c'est un
petit peu vide et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup moins de monde la plupart me
disaient qu'ils attendent impatiemment
de savoir ce qu'il va en découler de ce
rendez-vous aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement